là je vais rajouter un reflet il est
lui-même allergique aux produits
habituellement utilisés en 1997 samuel
cohen se lance dans la coloration 100%
végétale comme autrefois
je vous souhaite ma grand-mère faisait
elle même ses couleurs sa mère venue
tout jeune tout bébé j'avoue je voyais
ma grand mère sur ses couleurs d'automne
et ça m'est revenue je suis dit il faut
il ya possibilité avant autrefois avant
qu'enfin de lutte chimique on faisait du
végétal en faut se préparer les couleurs
de nous-mêmes soi même les coiffeurs
travail faisait ça donc je me suis bien
faire chaque couleur est le fruit d'une
recherche minutieuse au bout de 20 ans
samuel cohen peut proposer 29 couleurs à
base de plantes de végétaux et d'argile
quand il ya la pose du produit il n'y a
pas cette sensation qu'on a de brûlures
de sensation de voler haut niveau de
cash venu quand on rentre au niveau de
l'odorat il n'y a pas d'agressivité au
niveau de l'odeur tout et on sent que
c'est vraiment des produits qui sont
bons que c'est qu'ils sont pas nocifs et
ensuite au niveau du jeu il est beaucoup
plus d'eau beaucoup plus doux et
beaucoup moins sec
l'établissement versailles et est
labellisé développement durable des
institutions de la coiffure comme trois
autres salons dans le département